-NBC held the third Republican
presidential debate last week,
but there's still
some important questions
that have gone unanswered.
So we decided to hold
a debate of our own.
That's right.
All five candidates
are right here, right now,
and they're ready to go.
So without further ado,
here is the "Late Night"
Republican presidential debate!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Crowd murmuring ]
Welcome to "Late Night's"
first 2024 Republican
presidential debate.
I'm your moderator, Seth Meyers.
Let's jump right in.
Ambassador Haley, what was
the most surprising thing
you learned during your time
as an ambassador to the UN?
-China is real.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Governor DeSantis, what is
your biggest accomplishment
as governor of Florida?
-A significant decline
in life expectancy.
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. Ramaswamy, you said,
if elected, you'd ban Elmo. Why?
-He's a puppet
for the managerial class!
[ Laughter ]
-Governor Christie,
how would you describe yourself
on this stage tonight?
-One of the big failings
among many.
-Senator Scott -- Wait. Didn't
you drop out over the weekend?
What are you doing here?
-If you're able-bodied
in America, you work.
-You know you're still
a sitting senator, right?
-Mr. Ramaswamy, what does
"The New York Times" use
to print their newspaper?
-Woke Inc.
-Boo! Boo!
-Let's not do this.
Let's not do this.
Let's let the candidates speak.
-Hey, you moderate
the debate your way, Lester!
And I'll moderate it mine! Boo!
Governor Christie, moving on,
you are a board-game enthusiast.
What's your strategy when
you play the game Battleship?
-The submarines are the single
most important thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Ambassador Haley, it's time
for our music trivia round.
Answer this correctly,
and you'll get
five points in the polls.
Who sang the classic
R&B hit "September"?
-Land, Air and Sea.
-Mnh.
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
It's close enough.
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
Governor DeSantis,
what is the current average age
of the U.S. Senate?
-Stone-cold dead.
[ Laughter ]
-Governor Christie, why do you
want to become president?
-To defeat Hitler.
-We already defeated Hitler.
[ Laughter ]
Mr. Ramaswamy, this next
question is about health care.
What are your four favorite
euphemisms for sex?
-Drill. Frack. Burn coal.
Embrace nuclear.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, in high school,
I never got to embrace nuclear.
[ Laughter ]
Governor DeSantis,
who ya got --
Streisand or Celine Dion?
-I will take the Barbs.
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. Ramaswamy,
if you could time-travel
to any year throughout history,
what years
would you go to visit?
-2018. 2020. 2022.
-Those are -- It's just, like,
kind of all really recent years,
and I think you're failing
to fully take advantage
of this hypothetical
opportunity.
Are there any other years
you'd like the chance
to travel back to?
-2023.
[ Laughter ]
-I'd like to go back in time
and, uh...
to when we wrote that one.
[ Laughter ]
"It's not gonna work
the way you think!"
[ Laughter ]
Governor Christie, as president,
why would you bring back
low-rise jeans?
-To Increase
American naval power.
[ Laughter ]
-That's great.
Senator Scott, the Actor's Guild
finally settled their strike
after 118 days.
And picketing tips
for the next time
so it doesn't last so long?
-You have to strike in Iran
if you want to
make a difference.
[ Laughter ]
-That one actually went
exactly how I thought it would.
[ Laughter ]
Governor DeSantis,
you got a lot of heat
for eating pudding
with your fingers,
but that's the only thing
you eat in a weird way, right?
Like, how do you eat
an ice-cream cone?
-You gotta work
from the bottom up.
-So weird.
He's such a weird dude.
Mr. Ramaswamy, my 7-year-old son
wants to look cooler at school.
Any advice?
-I would tell him to smoke.
-Okay.
Governor Christie,
how would you describe
the Charmin Bears?
-A terrorist group
that has committed to wiping.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of them
end their sentences weird.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean? Like...
Like there's another word.
I don't know.
Ambassador Haley,
what do you call it
when someone shows a little skin
in exchange
for some free body art?
-Tit for tat.
[ Laughter ]
-Governor DeSantis,
what did your wife say
when she saw all the credit-card
charges for heel lifts?
-"I'm canceling your visa."
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. Ramaswamy, I heard
you released a new fragrance.
What's it called?
-Sexual responsibility for men.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
Hey, Governor Christie.
Check it out.
I found a dollar lying
over by the vending machines.
-Shame on you. You shouldn't
be taking the money.
-Geez. It's --
It's just a dollar.
-I find that
morally reprehensible.
-You okay, buddy?
-I'm tired.
[ Laughter ]
-I get it.
Hey, Mr. Ramaswamy,
how many Adderalls did you take
before this debate?
-Thousands!
[ Laughter ]
-Senator Scott,
where do you think
my childhood dog is right now?
-A farm in Iowa.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks.
Governor DeSantis!
Governor Haley!
Starts saying numbers of ships!
Go!
-355 ships.
-350 ships.
-385 ships.
-400 ships.
-600 ships.
-Good job!
-Over 700 --
-Stop it, Ron!
We're done with ship numbers!
Okay?!
That bit is over,
and you ruined it! "700."
Where would you even park
700 ships?
[ Laughter ]
Governor Christie,
what does eating at Chipotle
do to people's
lower G.I. system?
-It creates greater unrest
in the entire region.
-Hm.
Mr. Ramaswamy,
you seem upset with me.
Do you think someone else
should be moderating
this debate instead?
-This should be Tucker Carlson,
Joe Rogan, and Elon Musk.
We'd have 10 times
the viewership, asking questions
that GOP primary voters
actually care about.
-Okay. Good idea.
Let's let Elon Musk ask
a question and see how it goes.
-[ Chuckles ]
Are you a mushroom?
Do you like being in the dark
and feasting on dead --
dead plant and animal matter?
-Alright.
Would anyone like to respond
to Mr. Musk's terrific question?
Governor DeSantis, you look like
you have something
you want to say to Elon.
-You should not have money.
-Ambassador Haley.
Ambassador Haley,
what's the best place
to fart on an airplane?
-We have to go and start
beefing up the middle class.
[ Laughter ]
-Just call it "coach."
Mr. Ramaswamy, what method would
you use to assassinate Grimace?
-Fentanyl in a Big Mac.
-Governor DeSantis,
you look miserable.
Do you even
want to be president?
-I just want
to get back to Florida.
-Yeah.
-Governor Christie,
what's the wildest thing
you did in college?
-Foursome.
-Well...it looks like
we're out of time,
so on behalf of the candidates,
have a good night.
We'll be right back
with our friend Ed Helms.